table talk to a minimum avoid looking at
your cell phones and please do not
Heckle the performers now without
further Ado please put your hands
together for your host of the evening
they're very funny Hans Kim everybody
[Applause]
thank you guys it's good to be here
dating and getting to know females and
males my name is Hans Kim and I am the
betting expert for tonight thank you for
coming sir uh we're gonna have a great
time just getting to know people and
watching them trying to [__] each other
uh who here loves kill Tony
not that much love for kill Tony but uh
yeah this show is pretty much a direct
rip-off of kill Tony except with dating
yeah so hopefully that saves a lot of uh
explanation uh we can pick two people
out of the bucket and then we want some
date for 90 seconds which is different
from 60 which is killed Tony
and then we interview them afterwards so
that's that's going to be something that
we're gonna do soon uh we got a guest
tonight this guest is a man that's very
funny and also he's from Texas governor
for Dean Stanfield
[Applause]
the tequila soda there buddy yeah
yeah where are my dogs at
that's what I'm talking about dude I
[__] see you dog
each put your name in the bucket that's
what I want to know okay dude this guy's
a wild card is the dog like a Georgia
Bulldog or uh no dog is like a reference
to the boys dude all the boys have that
dog in them yeah
remember I got my dog
still waiting on mine is that like your
testicles to send it uh it can be it can
be uh sometimes ladies have dogs in them
you know oh [__] that can happen
lady with a dog in you
[Applause]
okay cocker spaniel overnight
that's an honorable dog dude all right
she got that dog well we talked about
this and we are actually sponsored by a
boat company Jeremy boat rentals we're
not sponsored by Jeremy boat rentals
yeah if you want to get on a boat party
boat this summer they got the Pontoon or
the ski boat for your needs and they're
gonna donate one free
Sunset Cruise for the best couple of the
night best couple let's try today
so what who is this guy Jeremy that
sounds a little so suspicious uh Jeremy
has been running boats on Lake Travis
ladybird and like Georgetown for over 25
years uh he has uh 12 votes in operation
so he's a legit he's not just a dude
he's not just a waste just gonna watch
you on a date no no no I will be the I
will be the it's also I am I work for
Jared so I do I do the party bus I'll be
the one doing the uh Yoga Yoga watching
yeah so if you want to go on a date with
Dean watching
there's like five other captains if you
don't want somebody else Mario is a lot
creepier than I am so
that's right no it's not easy what he is
yeah he's Italian I think he's Italian
oh gross yeah
the whites they're the whites the
Mexican any lady captains or is that yes
Megan green and uh there's a girl called
Monster uh she's she definitely has a
dog in there she does checklist
Marshall's got that dog she doesn't do
bachelorette parties she turns every one
of them down uh she wants the uh she
wants to she she handles the wild party
news is she the one that's killing all
the men in Austin right now I don't know
but if she did it you Justified hell
yeah man we are on woman's side all the
time you know I guess so you say that I
mean I look like a woman you don't look
like it thank you yeah you look like a
handsome young man or an ugly young
woman I don't need a lot of Asians so I
don't know yeah
[Music]
yeah
it was ready to watch some dates
[Applause]
I got a lot of dudes a lot of dudes here
hey that's fine hey that's fine
let's get to know a dude picked my Dean
Stanfield oh man this brings back some
just memories uh this is uh this is this
this fella has a really good name it's
uh Billy Ray Griffin Billy Ray Bill
you're right where the hell you at dude
give it up for Viara Griffin really
right oh come on Billy Ray what do you
got 30 times
[Music]
uh the next one we have is Danny McCoy
[Applause]
um
[Music]
yeah what kind of dog is inside you a
greyhound or like a
government I'm taking Labrador Retriever
mixed with most people described as a
golden retriever Great Dane without that
guy maybe a Great Dane you're very lanky
and long Saint Bernard about that book
and Got That Beef on you is that your
brother no what ah dude there's this
damn image dude
you guys look like a killer Halo team I
was like you didn't do you know you guys
look like you [__] people up on
fortnite
or in real life dude look in there
so long are you guys uh are a part of a
crew team you guys grow boats on
ladybird Lake yeah yeah really that's
[__] cool man it's the one thing
black people haven't done yet
this thing happened what the hell what
black person do you know that rose on a
boat okay I just don't know rowers but
I'm sure there's plenty of it I saw the
Gale team last year
what's your favorite race
Formula One damn right
it's close I shouldn't that's a damn
Frenchy sport
but some kind of racing I'll give you a
ball for it yeah if you save a driver F1
not burst out okay I'll respect that are
you single
currently yes nice what are you looking
for in a woman
[Music]
a pulse let's put it
let's put them in a hard situations let
me described somebody and somebody
opposite that comes up here it's like
just say broad thing to care open-minded
open-minded that's big enough that's
what things have open-minded yeah uh
should we get to know a lady tonight
please let's go that's Daddy's new
girlfriend that's the best
man Rose
[Applause]
[Music]
it's very open-mindedness people it's
just a great career
she's killing me
your mind's so open she got her hair
color oh he pulls the chair out look at
that that's 10 points right there
90 seconds starting now
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah we have a lot in common I see
[Music]
all right yeah and so how long have you
been here since uh moving from London
I've been in America for three years
I've been in Austin one yet where uh
well before this Boston I brought you
two months my friend
and time good up for Danny and Rose
[Applause]
cut Danny with the
pierced to tat and Rose what kind of
crazy thing would you show Danny on your
first date like maybe how to like punch
a dude in the face I could do that
it's gonna take some people down
absolutely you can be my Robin it'll be
cute all right wow he's already got a
jiu jitsu partner out there which is
that's pretty good sounds flexible
panties
fat boy comments
loving it Danny what's the closest
you've come to getting a tab or a
piercing
I don't have a tab I thought about
getting one before but uh I don't know
my grandpa said something pretty uh
pretty special about this topic and uh
you know you know you don't put a bumper
sticker on Ferrari
over there
why why haven't you had a tattoo are you
uh a seat baby
you're on a Ferrari you gotta find a
piece of you know specimen you don't
want to Market them whatever kind of you
know stuff you're going to want I got
tons of tattoos I'm on your side though
I got I got nothing against tattoos I
just haven't got one yet but I always
love asking people about those they're
usually do you know what people with
tattoos hate being asked about yeah
do you know how many people are like oh
what does that mean they're like I don't
know Jerry like I don't know I got it
when I was 14 I'm an idiot Club
sorry
sounds so much better with the British
accent
so if you're trying to convince Danny to
get a tattoo how would you do it what
would you say to him what would I say
that yeah
I'd probably just taking my time and
getting drunk that's why most people get
sad it's more so about just how many
drinks around us
all the way to Thailand he's American he
doesn't travel that's true
so uh Danny you've been uh noticing her
teeth you did some like dental work or a
dental observations uh are you uh you
you look at teeth a lot is that like are
you have a teeth fetish
as a facility a strong word but yeah I
think uh teeth is uh it's a good
indicator I love a girl with a good
smile Rose has got a great smile
[Applause]
I think that means he wants to [__] you
uh
Danny uh
what's like your favorite kind of tea
I have no idea you're supposed to say
mine
straight
British cheese
are they are they yours originals are
those oh geez
yeah okay cool no actually no that's a
lie
front one is
something crazy
and they're a girlfriend
the first two that I ever lost was on
Christmas Eve the same night of like
Santa came as a kid that's what my
parents convinced me that like the Tooth
Fairy was going to meet Santa Claus that
night and so I kind of thought you know
something special would happen but nice
stuff she just like yanked it out for
her yeah it's kind of just got a dollar
bro that's the most metal thing I've
ever heard of I don't think that Rose
would have done that pulled his teeth
out when she was good I don't think that
looking at you you would have shook the
tooth on a vodka bottle yeah
can't say I have yet do you drink a lot
or do you just look like that
uh I drink enough
he drinks like a tank
uh so uh if you were to show Rose around
America the place of freedom and guns
where would you take her
to show show her the real American
Experience
Terlingua Texas hello dude that's a
that's a great place man how do you know
about tour lingual I took a road trip
there in January it's always fun it's
sick [__] yeah nice what would you do in
totally what uh hike it's uh right there
Big Ben so I love that spot I was very
out of place though a lot of cowboys and
just seven men there and you want to do
the most California thing possible in
front of them go for a hike
I mean that is what you do in Big Ben so
it's all cowboy I mean you take
mushrooms and Hike but both those
activities are very Capricorn hell yeah
I can oh
foreign
[Applause]
ing the whole time like why
[Music]
I don't know like
a man wants to go on a hike
okay that's fine have you ever uh been
uh on a date and had it go horribly
horribly wrong in a funny way
I don't think I can certainly not coming
to number eight I'm like a horrible way
that first states that if they're born
thank you for offering that detail
[Music]
s you put your hands in somebody's [__]
yeah yeah okay yeah she's like did you
reach into the toilet did he [__] on
your car and you haven't moved it what
was it did you accidentally just put
your hand back on a doctor
can eat [__] in the bed
oh [__] was he sleeping naked
so uh We've Just Had Sex
so you didn't [__] the [__] out of it
[Applause]
Danny this could be you in a couple
hours
start drinking that vodka
dang have you ever [__] your pants
actually yes
I will give us the details yeah my
senior year of college and it was my
best friend's birthday and I wanted to
do something special so I got a vacate
it I I got him a cake before we went out
but I'm allergic to chocolate and so I
had like three pieces of cake we went
out that night and we're like I got this
[__] [__] so it's like 2 A.M I'm
walking home and it just starts like I
can't make it and I just like pull over
and like to someone's yard and back up
to their bushes and then their flood
light like came on motion detected and
the neighbor across the street came out
and saw me and I just pulled up my pants
I've never told anyone uh none of my
friends in college know that they knew
my buddies here wow so what a great
story did you actually [__] your pants
as you make it out loud uh
no
allergic to chocolate that's kind of
racist
[Music]
I kind of found out you're allergic to
chocolate that night you said you do
prior yeah that's such a bold mood to be
like I know I'm allergic to it
you bought the cake and then you ate
three slices what did you think was
gonna happen I was drunk enough and
wanted it enough so I don't regret it
is
shot I was shooting in someone's yard
when was it I can't keep taking it
that's chocolate on chocolate violence
right there
Rosa what do you think this guy knows
how to party he eats chocolate cake
[Music]
that's British for gay
yeah
he said College like recently so you
guys I don't know American stuff I don't
know
we don't have multiples and I still
haven't graduated college are you like
24 yeah
24 dude look right for 24 brother
could have gone either 22 to 28.
I've heard a lot more of them
so you're from Wisconsin or Minnesota or
something same thing yeah
cool I got a good race tracks up there
nice trash America is it Wisconsin
do you did you you [__] with that the
Wisconsin thing all the racing strikes
yeah race tracks in Wisconsin uh
snowmobile trail okay wow it's
close it's close Rose what do you think
about this American he's really into
burning oil he really yeah stereotypical
Americans
do you uh do you drive a hybrid or do
you take the bus I found a moped oh yeah
so British
uh do you have a pickup truck you can
put the moped in
oh I got a shitty 2011 Ford
LS what kind all right Ford Escape
running into the ground dude I got a
2006 Ford Escape out there
well not sure it's like a really shitty
Safari looking View
you guys want to touch tips or something
does it uh does it encourage you that he
has a vehicle named after your exit
strategy skateboard
anyways
Danny what do you think you think that
uh there's something uh that you could
tell her in your American way with your
American accent that would really get
the ball rolling for the next date
uh I'm certainly not one to prefer to
pick up lines but uh
well that's too bad is there anything
you say like to make sure this this day
goes to a second one
I mean
this is a joke
okay I think he might be gay
Rose is there anything you'd like to say
to Danny just to uh come see what's it
like being Ginger and having no soul
damn dogs
why I don't like violence you'll love to
see that she got spider tattoo
underneath do something like that
[Music]
that's like a prison tattoo
on her name with your accent I heard a
person tattoo a spider tattoo prison
tattoo oh it is well like you know
Hispanic guys get it on their skulls
oh maybe I have it because it's a cartel
player you got the knee of a Mexican man
Mexican guys
well you guys are a very beautiful
couple and I think you could win a trip
on a boat
um
all right we'll give it up for Rose good
day
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
getting up like a man
like the dog that Danny was
how's your uh how's your day in your
life like are you single right now
um
okay so yes
no conscious yeah uh well that's cool
that's uh you're out on the scene
looking for dick
are they bi or are you uh as well
um it depends on how drunk I am
she went to college oh yeah so uh what's
your favorite thing about men nowadays
um
thank you
okay it's a tough one to crack boys
you like to take care of them yes like
support them financially and things I
like to be a show fellas
nobody else wants to uh
don't do that are you uh are you willing
to clean up some uh some if a man shits
are you willing to clean it up for him
no okay sorry Daddy
[Music]
so uh yeah did you uh you uh here with a
beautiful man over there
what's his name his name is Brian Brian
are you a sugar baby brother baby
[Music]
I take care of them nice that's awesome
that's a lot of
my pants
I kind of consider him my future
ex-boyfriend but hello
that's hot uh loving it some dude is uh
gonna come up here oh we're gonna find
out I don't know how many times they put
Danny's name in this [__]
I do after two more days
who signed you up if you sign up another
person you have to go out next is it
yeah it's dating him holy [__] Billy
Ray's back in here [__] each other on
the stage afterwards there's like 30
dudes in here they can't all be Danny
McQueen eloise.com
[Music]
tomorrow
yeah
my favorite color is purple yes
and money yeah
oh that's simple yeah
[Music]
um
what's happening here I mean it was
still less than me but
um
[Music]
listen
um
[Music]
[Applause]
give it up for
talking good about my boss thank you
that's interesting to say in front of a
date and throughout the day what she
said
oh you want him to spit in your mouth
the him
I know it's just got a handsome
gentleman in front of her and she wants
the fair enough fair enough a tiny fairy
you're spitting him out
that's my boss I know I'm sorry you're
very Charming for about 50 seconds and
then you run out of questions
yeah pretty much yeah
you could be any race you could be about
seven different races
and how much you gotta do it I'd rather
not
thank you
all right I'm gonna cook it in three
though I'm actually getting good
oh hey what's uh how did you get your
smoothness your swampness where does
this come from Pinch pinch
I've been on hinge it doesn't make me
that much smoother let's have a backflip
off let me check it out like ten dollars
thank you ten bucks oh my God again am I
gonna have big beautiful eyes by the end
of this I don't think so much
Taylor what did you think about aloe on
this state he was a very smooth talker I
guess that's so smooth you couldn't even
hear him
I was trying to get a little personal
you know I feel like the rest of the
crowd I'm not here excuse me right now
it's a fun place to get personal it's on
on a stage in front of people
we wanted to make the 90 seconds person
yeah very personal intimate
[Music]
so you guys are both here with other
people what do you what do you think how
would you like it if they went on a date
in front of you would that be a little
weird
songs
Taylor's about that eight mile energy
where are you from I'm from Wisconsin
oh nice that guy was from Wisconsin
um
so what's uh
so what did you think about Wisconsin
are you happy you're out of there no it
literally makes me so depressed it's so
cold
I hate it nice
and I'm here just killing it just taking
names making 170k a year oh yeah you
make 170k what are you doing to make
170k a year battery engineer battery
engineer yep damn that's intense I bet
that is I bet that does Payless what do
you work with double A or AAA
online
you must have a vibrator that never
quits
laughs it's got a handy on that Bible
idea you got any battery needs that
Taylor could satisfy
batteries
[Music]
lawn mower
yeah
he's not Hispanic there goes one guest
now
he's not the last time this year too
Taylor nuts all right you make so much
money what do you uh what do you like
about paying for men do you love to see
the the
Dynamic but like I also love taking care
of people
this is why women should rule the world
they can just pay for everything and
that's right well that's cool you make a
lot of money although hey you don't look
like you make that much money
what the fancy rooms he's got on
enough nice what uh what do you like to
spend your money on
besides not getting haircuts just sit
back in um basketballs traveling you
know travel where are you from are you
from Austin I'm from Houston
yeah okay that's you travel to get here
is like
Indian or no I'm not I told you about
this
I think Taylor's wife
you would be cracked what's your
favorite
have you ever dated a man of ethnic
descent before
uh no wow so this could be your first
that's awesome
yeah he's uh had sex with lots of people
apparently he just wanted you to know
that real
quickie room
I think that's what they've been talking
about
it is
[Music]
ripped for her pleasure
hello what's your favorite sexual
technique in the bedroom
[Music]
what country it is that's not a good
question
anyways
I just wanted to know how many
uh how how big of a suicide best you can
handle
sexy pounder oh yeah
Taylor what's uh what's your favorite
part of dating white men exclusively
[Music]
um
I usually I think they're smarter than
me and then you pay for their [__]
hello what do you uh think you have
above white men that you could offer to
Taylor on the date you aren't doing the
same thing because you have a track
record and all you need it as long as
you should come on
hello hey I love it you're financially
Savvy
I am Indian
that's why I'm gonna say by the way
this is cool yeah it's on PornHub a
couple times
[Music]
so what exactly is your situation alloy
with your date over here
[Music]
success yeah we talked about that
well she's in the bucket too so she's
coming up next she's beautiful I'm with
it
University
[Music]
him too
so Taylor and he uh what's what's like
your uh guess as to what race alloy is
cool right now
Southern Indian
she did it online
[Music]
what's the is there I probably shouldn't
be I shouldn't let this down um
okay cool
I think he made a Mexican joke
it was great to find out your race
what's your uh do you know any Kamasutra
moves
just show us on stage
[Music]
you don't [__] on the stage
that's some common suture I rest up have
you ever read that book no dude you want
to read it yeah redneck has read a book
that I haven't read I feel horrible you
should though it's got a lot of pictures
in it
it's a picture but it's a picture book
basically
yeah you guys can do a little Jiu Jitsu
of teach Rose a couple moves
[Music]
along financially yes
okay he made a little lunch there but
luckily it was a joke
was it was it
girl also can fight you and shut up
that's what it is she reminds me of the
who's the bear girl in uh Game of
Thrones the lady Roma
of a little girl the girl more girl or
or the yeah this is what you cover my
meals yeah she [__]
so yeah that's hot uh yeah I love it so
yeah you uh
what's what do you think do you think
she reminds you of like a a character
from a TV show that you'd want to have
sex with that's not a child
it's okay
oh Taylor
it's not white you can't say that
there's no one in jail now
[Music]
I love it I don't know who's gonna be
the alpha in this relationship it seems
like you can turn this in a scissor no
sure
[Music]
I'm glad you're not a dude because you'd
be a joker type person
uh have you ever committed any crimes
besides
uh smoking Methodist Wisconsin
[Music]
oh thank you sorry I was trying to
arrest you no just a lot of them
but honestly
she's looking for his accents just in
case that's uh that's an awesome thing
that I am happy I got to see you know a
beautiful strong white woman with a
beautiful
smooth cool whatever you are if you're a
southern Indians
um yeah you guys uh you guys want to
rock paper scissors to see who's gonna
be on the bottom laughs
[Music]
I also going over official rules for
them
oh nice the man wins again thank God
[Applause]
well
please let us know how this goes film it
baby
just hashtag it or something but thank
you for coming on and uh yeah that was
amazing I was really bad enough to
confused yeah
he's never gone back to white dudes
again
let's get another date hey we do want to
pick out for us
beautiful woman
uh Wendy
Whitney coming up hey everyone's over
here my friend of Rose
hopefully she's not British
[Music]
oh [__]
she's as American as you get that's
where they did the t-pos and such right
yeah
show them dirty bricks yeah
like
[Music]
I was really scared so while she's
scarier yeah
what did you do
yeah oh thank you darling I appreciate
it whoever this is um
so how do you know Rose uh we met in
Boston I was she came in uh to my salon
with the middle of her head shape oh you
hairdressing that man okay
so what do you think about Dean's hair
as a hairdresser looks a little
dehydrated does it yeah there's a little
conditioner
I put coconut oil in it I was in the
swamps coconut oil in it really that
creates like a layer on the X it's not
good oh it's not good thank you
um what do you think about the mullet do
you think that's coming back
uh I do I do a lot of mullets so it pays
my bills they're starting it they're
starting to pop up everywhere yeah they
are you are in Texas after all yeah well
it goes with this flow
Danny I'm just going to give you every
single one of these Dandy cards
so uh what are you looking for in a date
someone who can make me laugh
some some I'm in a relationship so this
is
the open to other like is it a close
relationship she's very close yeah okay
is he here no okay well we're filming
this
when the cat's awake and my support yeah
you know what they say just FYI is here
[Music]
this next guy is gonna have to go on a
date and then a marathon the Boston
Marathon oh [__] is your boyfriend's a
bomb expert
what is it is your boyfriend jealous
type is it Dallas type no I am oh so if
you saw him on a date on stage with
another girl what would you do to his
balls I let's do his balls yeah
um I don't know I tried to get him to
come here because I wanted him to go on
the show
be part of it I didn't want to get
murdered yeah no I don't know that I
would do anything to do with balls I
would maybe do something to the girl I
will always love that honey that does
make sense they are weaker and easier to
catch
what would you do to this poor woman
that might not have known well
this is just a simulation so I don't
know that I would do anything seriously
I am a jealous type though I don't know
I would probably do you could tell that
by the tabs and a haircut
just a simulation yeah
I think I'm real please don't kill me
I think I'm really here this feels
pretty real to me I don't know if I have
a small of a deck if this was a single
issue what are that dude's doing up
there but give me an upgrade so I'm
playing a massive joke on me
what's the smallest dick that you've
ever been with
um
this big and uncircumcised what was his
name
is
saying the size of his thumb it was not
[__] thumbs up but it was the size of
myself
wow you might as well [__] a woman
it was like a big [__]
you guys scissors
it makes my stomach upset what are you
gonna talk about that
you don't like talking about the small
dicks I don't know like that's just yeah
do you have a smell deck no
there's no way you have a bullet and a
small dick that's one of the other
that's true
well that made me feel better
I'm at least a pinky finger hell yeah
dude
um that's cool do you uh you like your
boyfriend's dick right now yeah it's way
cool yeah it's a lot cool wait [__]
cool what's the coolest thing about it
is it like curved or is there a pimple
on it
you're my pleasure it's just bumpy no
no he's gotta he's got a nice uh setup
for sure
I don't want to talk about his dick well
what now here's my question you know
that you're shacked up what about one of
these fellas is in here looking for love
and he comes up here you think you could
be persuade do they have a chance to to
jump the fence and get old big hog out
of the bedroom we cannot try okay with
that you're willing to it opens keep it
[__] right let's try yeah that's all
right he's got the let's see he's got
the gumption the change the lady that's
what I'm talking about hey can I get Cam
up here can I get Cam up here
he's a comic he's handsome as hell
you can sign up
[Music]
[Applause]
are you rapping to me right now
hey what that what that City when you
sing to a [__]
it's not working yeah
[Applause]
thank you
what is it what is it is it shirt yeah
what do you say you'll see oh
that's the trap
a ton of them left over so I thought oh
[__]
there you go yeah baby
[Applause]
I didn't know what I was working with it
I feel like you like bigger shirts
though yeah your pants and even off your
ass
you
know
outside
the airport
[Applause]
never met a black person before
[Music]
that's right yeah
come on man
I got a bless my [__] I'm a genius are
you still rapping with me I'm Sarah
naked you yes
the serenation
of God so does this always sound like
rapping when you hear black people
I feel like Wendy's about to call the
cops on the camera
after she come yes
oh wow this is amazing cam what do you
like so much about Whitney's cheeks yeah
tell me more it's just like they like
they really like you know what I'm
saying
thank you I really love it
they're real nice and real pretty and
plunk
it's like you've got good uh
yeah yeah I put cocoa butter on my skin
that's why I didn't believe you yeah how
tall
I is
[Music]
really
[Applause]
Stan who I just want to see that ass man
he's got four cheeks than you love all
of them
oh my God
well that stopped the momentum
so uh are you uh are you into black guys
you said you dated a half black guy yeah
he was half
Jamaican and like German that was a
weird mix oh it was crazy yeah it wasn't
long-lived we could make some ribs to
sitting in that black babies
[Music]
oh
no no okay
uh Campbell what's up
what uh what do you think about uh
Whitney's pants and
like she's criticizing her pants like I
I like okay I like it it's different you
have socks on like flip-flops right now
yeah
I lived in Orlando right off
International behind the Hooters yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you talking to [__]
laughs
hey so you said you had a problem with
the socks and the and the slides would
you rather him go uh socks inside a shoe
yeah no no no okay so it's the slides
you got a problem with it well I got
went Barefoot yeah I got a lot of
clothes do you have socks on would you
Crocs
I go bathroom see but I got ugly tools
huh yeah you better put those away or
charge someone to look at those things
right I climb I climb trees you do the
nasty ass toes huh no they're not nasty
asses yeah
I'm so mean
you guys don't cry honey don't be
looking at other guys while you're
cheating on your boyfriend
yes
mind your business I don't love guns I
don't like guns I hate them too
that's a dangerous and they kill people
yeah they're fine what else you don't
like
racist
I'm having a good time right now I'm
glad you're having a good time this [__]
is fun it's fun yeah
I've seen you performed twice and every
time I'm like oh my God this guy's crazy
here I am in love
man
keep being yourself
went over [__] get that [__]
I gotta talk with my Consultants
you look like you eat [__]
you look a little promiscuous
these are serenade a lot of women
all right you guys are just about to get
around how you got around
I love this this looks like Cam's
meeting his parole officer
[Applause]
what's the craziest thing you did in
Orlando when you were living there what
kind of Hooters so what do you do for
what why do you have a hairdresser
oh yeah do most hairdressers have shirts
with
oh my hairdresser and then I do
burlesque into that bottle like that
that's almost that's like scrippy right
a little bit fancy stripping yeah yeah
that shirt is from that yeah yeah
[Music]
I need you to be loyal oh I'm sorry
I got you
below to me
[Music]
not being Wicked oh my God right now
oh that's a Boston Slater yeah
all right let's see let's go yeah it's
so awaken we say [__] yeah
I like how you said it was hotter
[Music]
[__] when you say it
bro what are you doing you're doing good
I like this yeah
this is nice that was good yeah is there
anything any Florida slang that you can
teach Whitney
oh oh what's that [__] [__]
something she could say oh wow
hey I'll give you permission to say it
you said we married already
we all ready to go together
[Music]
okay you're not gonna say it I thought
you were from Boston but obviously that
is probably the most awesome thing I
could say I like my accent yeah that's
crazy I like I like her accent
your accent's a little difficult
sometimes
you got to stick a tongue out yeah
[Music]
I mean she loved me already
can you cook I'm Sicilian yeah
I can cook I like to cook
Sicilian food I don't know what the [__]
that is [__] Italian food
Italian and Sicilian are two different
things kind of sort of but yeah okay
okay
yeah spaghetti and pizza yeah
I like me a good slices
what do you cook
to me
[Applause]
that's what I was gonna say
yeah
I do like fried pork chops
this is my this is what this is what I
do right we're going to date what's up
what's up they didn't even pull your
name out of a damn cup I just called you
up
I know they were like oh she's from
Boston with each other what's up perfect
what's so obviously
have you ever been out of the country
yeah
right so first we wake up like 61 black
packing bags [__] we leave with a
country right
[Music]
can you afford to pay for that extra bag
on Spirit now come on yeah
so we go to Italy right getting internet
on someone and I get one of them faster
[__] to get the boat with the stick
[Applause]
[Music]
while you're on the boat and you go
under the tunnel I'm gonna start saving
wood on the stairs
and I'm gonna have I'm gonna have some
red sticks and so got that on Samsung
breakfast or Ranch sticks yes I'm gonna
have a little bit of what I like what
you like okay
put it all on the pizza you know eat
your ass
whoa obviously
any course meal on the boat
the first thing yeah
you guys look like you're mad at a Tech
Nine concert
well should we get one more date up here
and then yeah yeah I mean this this has
been a fantastic day that was that was
that yeah yeah
[Applause]
Amanda lady Let's uh yeah let's do it
the way that God intended Jimmy Steve uh
Jimmy C coming up to interview real
quick somebody said he's gone I think
Jimmy Clifford here Jimmy's gone what
about Billy Ray they said Billy Rays
[__] in here again
is it I bet there's six of them
Danny which one of your friends signed
you up well it's all different
handwriting that's I think every single
one of them which one which one do you
want to see up here right now which
[__] do you want to see up here the
guy with the Liberty Bell or glasses
I should look straight to that [__]
Spotlight don't let your friends prank
you like this
they won't respect her in the frat house
anymore
are you gonna pick a friend of yours
Dylan Mizuki
ironic face are they oh no they're not
they're Nikes Dylan would suit you've
done with the show before right yeah
yeah you're Italian yep oh yeah what do
you think about cam saying that he's
going to take a woman on a gondola dude
he stole all my lines you know no yeah
he's good you were gonna say
bad word
[Music]
uh what are you looking for in a woman
um
uh you know uh kindness
yeah and uh you know a good personality
and good luck is saying buzzwords now I
don't know
hey look I'm gonna have a lot of dating
shows this is a nightmare it's um
awesome like
huh
what do you look for in a woman what do
you mean or for the first time what
sticks out
she's got to be a Vibe you know oh yeah
what kind of music are the tricks that
you're into into
um I mean I usually end up with hippie
chicks okay you know Grateful Dead and
fish are really like that so white
chicks
uh so far you're like Taylor
Taylor's wife yeah she's I feel bad for
this guy though what's going on she just
trying to talk to him I don't know
what what's happening you drew a woman
yeah Kaylee Kayla C Kaylee see ya
here
what do you think Dylan are you ready
for this date no
[Music]
let's see
[Applause]
how's it going
I'm a little nervous all right that
makes me feel better
[Music]
oh well
where are you from
[Music]
did you know you live here
cool yeah I've been here for like two
months from Austin New York
here it's good you know but almost
but other than that it's pretty cool
um
oh my God the main difference is
Mexicans with mullets I think
I did not see that where I was from
they're just so used to it I don't know
no I'm not gonna buy the towel Blues I'm
not gonna say y'all
and we didn't feel safe you know
yeah why'd you move here
where are you running away from
this is
nothing
I originally got moved here because I I
considered with my STL today but
okay we can dive into that
[Music]
time yeah give it up for dinner
[Applause]
you brought up homeless people Mexicans
and her ex-fiance and then the trifecta
up dates it's a good start
let's get started Dylan what uh what do
you think that you can offer uh Kayla
you'd be uh on top of like uh her
ex-fiance what do you think you have
above your her ex-fiance um I'm probably
way nicer than him
but
and then I'll I'll you know I'm gonna
I'll smother you
what I will probably leave me that's
probably what happened security
um
I no I think I used to be
that's what happened
I don't know
um
it became 30 years old yeah you just
well it just doesn't help you it's no
good it's like worrying
you know it just it makes things worse
oh solidarity in the first time it's
great they're getting over their
relationships trauma their trauma
bonding right now
Dylan have you ever been abandoned and
ditched
I've been broken up with so yeah I guess
how did that make you feel not good okay
invisible
what happened with your ex-fiance he's
just uh you guys moved here together and
then what happened
we were like broken
[Music]
I was cheating just the cheese it's just
um it's not good nice
a son of a [__] yeah Dylan have any
guys these eyes work these eyes don't
cheat yeah it doesn't too much of an
expensive I just got a cop on my eyes
earlier huh from another man another man
in compliments with my eyes
have you ever tried the like 30 seconds
of uninterrupted eye contact
that's supposed to be like a romantic
thing right to see if you're compatible
with somebody if you can hold eye
contact does that make for a great
podcast
[Music]
in 30 seconds
so okay how do you you really love that
Asian joke
[Music]
that's the best
I can see why your fiance left here
it's
[Music]
Kelly uh Dylan has a very beautiful
features that Ben seem to love he's been
complimented twice today what do you
think about dating a man that is so
attractive to other men
I first of all I said yeah
it's feminine energy right so yeah he's
a two to this feminine side
no he's not as a man
don't want to talk like that dude there
you go Dylan do you protest
that I have feminine energy yeah
I mean everyone does so he does the
levels you know yeah
I think he's very well-rounded person oh
thanks what's like the manliest thing
that you've done last week did you fight
anyone or uh I I cut fish
were they alive when he did it
I did not catch it you had a man catch
it for you
yeah well you know lots of real men
catch it they bring it to this fish
market
damn you work at a fish market yeah oh
[__] that's a badass job yeah it's
really good at eating [__] because he's
used to the snob yeah
[Music]
yes I love how you disagree
yes and or something
so Dylan is uh very very in tune with
both sides of his gender
uh kaylia are you uh are you pretty
girly what's like the girls thing that
you're into besides Dylan
you're a spinner herself
like
[Music]
that's okay
she likes makeup and hiking and camping
sorry yeah I feel like I'm pretty
well-rounded like I like different
countries the most masculine thing about
you is probably how you're not good at
holding shaped object to your face
[Music]
that's cool you like hiking and being
outside and camping
it's also Dylan's favorite way to murder
I I do
I do like murder no
um
I do like hiking and camping actually it
looks like you could murder me in the
woods so thank you so much
is that a turnout is that a good thing
did your fiance ever make you fear for
your life
[Music]
oh
very sympathetic he cheated already
[Music]
he wouldn't he wouldn't kill him
would kill one
he cuts his shoulders right they're
already dead
I had to kill lobsters
Dylan what's something that you could do
for Kaylee on a hiking camping trip
that's pretty manly
uh are those his butthole
I went uh backpacking once I don't know
wait is this a manly question again yeah
you want backpacking box no she's like
hiking and camping what can you do to
take her on a hike in a camping
Adventure
what was you saying to her during this
hiking trip to make her feel like you
know what you're doing out there
um I can identify uh maybe some herbs if
I remember that oh you can identify
something
how does it feel to be with Amanda
it's an armologist
so do you when you go camping what do
you like to do besides
Dylan uh
what uh what do you like to do in the
woods
um like uh smoking weed walking around
looking at stuff thank you
Applause yeah there's something gonna
hold it what is this Greg Abbott
[Music]
what
I mean not really I was kind of that's
kind of reaching
but hey but if you don't know what
plants are it's pretty manly to be like
that's Yara yeah yeah
well that sounds like Robin That's
Pelican
three leaf clover yeah
there's one I was trying to think of one
oh fiddlehead I could organize a
fiddlehead
I'm talking about that yeah talk about
camel like that
uh
what are you what is your favorite thing
about a woman
Taylor what's your favorite thing about
a man
okay make Kaylee laugh right now no put
on the spot dog
no you gotta have baby one you don't
have a you have a built-up joke your
Grandpa didn't tell you a joke for this
context
I'm gonna take a swing dude
[Music]
um
well once I want a day with the chick
and it's going well see that's not it
all right it could yeah
no no okay yeah well we have to go back
to our apartment you know it's going
well but then we got the apartment she
had a huge Confederate flag on the wall
yeah that's a big red flag
oh
[Music]
I forgot where I was
no yeah would you date a Woman fly I
look like it would yeah a couple
ex-girlfriends have been waiting one of
them
thank you
see she's laughing dude she loves it
when you lie to me I like nervous laughs
so so that's the way you're saying now
cracking up in the woods alone with
Dylan
well give it up for a Dylan and Kayla
[Applause]
[Music]
let me know you're gonna be on a boat
soon dude
I picked the painless guy to go on the
boat
oh yeah thank you guys for coming that
was a blast everyone wasn't that fun
everybody was participating
[Applause]
[Music]
come back